herzlich willkommen meine damen und
herren heute reden wir mal über das
reden selbst über unsere sprache und die
einfluss auf unser denken meine hoffnung
ist dass wir am ende auch besser
verstehen werden was uns menschen zum
menschen macht schließlich ist der
mensch ja dass einige tiere das sprechen
kann
manche exemplare können sogar sehr gut
sprechen etwa mein heutiger gast philipp
oebel ist juniorprofessor für
philosophie in stuttgart und ein experte
wenz unsere sprache und um unser denken
geht herzlich willkommen herr niebel ja
ich habe etwas mitgebracht zum anfang
eine energy mit vielen dank eine beauty
colada und ein glück sie dürfen sich was
also ich hab ja eigentlich wasser wenn
ich jetzt was aussuchen muss würde ich
vielleicht den themen dem glück steht ja
ich hab ihn hier noch ein paar dazu
einen normalen kräutertee hätten sie den
abgenommen
ja mir ist das relativ egal was darauf
draufsteht ich würde jetzt schauen was
da für ein t drin ist aber natürlich
spielten spielen diese ganzen titel
darauf an dass wir produkte oder wort
dinge in der welt gut sprachlich
verpacken um sie zu verkaufen und das
merkt man im konsum besonders deutlich
also dieses phänomen fremming
sprachliche einrahmung sprachliche 1
packung funktioniert gut wenn die wörter
die wir verwenden irgendwie einen
positiven balance wert haben also glück
ist positiv beauty jeder möchte schön
sein und energie energie ist auch was
positives kann nicht schaden wenn man
das auf die produkte draufschreiben
werden wir wirklich glücklicher wenn ihr
den hier trinkt nach athen ich glaube
der hersteller wird glücklicher weil
mehr leute das also man kann nachweisen
dass wenn menschen nicht mit hoher
aufmerksamkeit und hohe reflexion zum
beispiel einkaufen gehen ein bisschen
empfänglich sind für die überhaupt für
die verpackung sowieso also die
physische verpackung aber auch für die
sprachliche verpackung und dass man so
was wie glücks tee dass das wort ein
bisschen ein in diese richtung drängen
kann man zahlt kann aber auch zeigen
dass wenn menschen gründlich nachdenken
oder eine einkaufsliste haben und sagen
ich trinke nur albert ii dann kann man
da so oft glück drauf schreiben wie man
will da wird das jemand deshalb trotzdem
kaufen jetzt haben sie schon ein
fachbegriff genannt fremming können sie
nochmal kurz erklären was das genau
bedeutet fremming heißt erstmal
einrahmung sprachlicher einrahmung
sprachliche verpackung und das erstmal
die beobachtung dass wir einen inhalt
mit der einen oder anderen weise
sprachlich in ein kleid einkleiden
können sozusagen und ein beispiel als
wir kennen das alle aus dem alltag ist
wenn jemand der immobilienmakler möchte
eine wohnung verkaufen das ist
eigentlich eine verstümmelte bruchbude
und dann sagt er das ist die künstler
wohnung mit shabby chic oder bei
kontaktanzeigen kennt man das ganz gut
da sagt dann jemand von sich selbst erst
der freiheitsliebende lebenskünstler und
in wirklichkeit ist er der beziehung
scheut man kann immer sozusagen mit den
worten das schön sozusagen in die eine
oder andere richtung drehen obwohl der
inhalt immer derselbe bleibt also beim
gras zum beispiel möchte ich noch ein
bisschen trinken dann könnte man sagen
halb voll oder halb leer aber eigentlich
genau das ist eine frage der perspektive
und die hoffnung ist beim training beim
einrammen also solche feministen
euphemismen die ich gerade genannt hat
beschönigung sind das beste beispiel die
hoffnung ist natürlich immer dass man
den anderen dazu mal ein bisschen eher
dazu bringen kann etwas positiv zu
finden und ein ort wo das besonders
gerne verwendet wird es natürlich die
politik weil die sprache der politik
muss ständig irgendwas gut verpacken
deshalb sagen politiker solidaritäts
zuschlag zum beispiel und sagen mich
zwangsabgabe weil solidarität positiv
besetzt zwang ist negativ besetzt wir
sagen humanitäre intervention und nicht
angriffskrieg kann manchmal dasselbe
sein aber das wort humanitäre
intervention klingt irgendwie positiver
oder flexible arbeitszeiten davon dass
oft die rede könnte auch sagen trägt
ihre angestellten situationen
unsicherheit unsichere
angestelltenverhältnis aber flexibel
klingt dann irgendwie positive in der
schweiz haben wir das beim bei den namen
von politischen initiativen zb den
heißen masseneinwanderung
initiative oder abzocker-initiative und
so weiter und die sind natürlich schon
stecken schon wer täterin würde ich mal
sagen oder bestimmte einstellungen ja
und genau bei politisch moralischen
debatten ist es besonders stark dass
dann entweder negativ oder positiv
gefällt wird also eingerahmt wird wenn
man es positiv darstellen will dann
macht man etwas mit freiheit und man es
negativ darstellt will irgendein
phänomen möchte macht man es eher mit
negativen sollte immer so ein bisschen
in die geschichte guckt und sich große
reden anschaut sieht man auch dass die
politiker sich schon immer die macht der
worte gezielt zunutze gemacht haben wir
alle haben sie im ohr die worte die die
welt bewegt haben
[Applaus]
große redner können etwas anstoßen ihre
zuhörer mitreißen und zu großen bewegen
[Musik]
dummerweise bewegen redner ihre zuhörer
auch dann wenn sie ihnen krieg bis zum
untergang versprechen
[Applaus]
ja und auch der gegenwärtig mächtigste
mann der welt donald trump verwendet die
sprache sehr effektiver verwendet
einfache worte konkrete bilder und viele
wiederholungen america america
[Applaus]
bild
ja herr über das macht denn die sprache
von donald trump so erfolgreich ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das jetzt wirklich
die sprache ist die ihnen da erfolgreich
macht also die linguisten würden sagen
hat oder psychologen würden sagen
wiederholung ist ein mechanismus um
sachen besonders zu betonen und man weiß
aus studien dass menschen die einen so
genannten intuitiven denkstil haben also
die für eher emotional spontan denken
und ihre aufmerksamkeit nicht so stark
anstrengen im gegensatz zu leuten ihren
analytischen denken haben und
wissenschaftlich denken reflektiert
denken also den intuitiven längst viel
hat ist für so wiederholungen anfällig
da gibt es den sogenannten exposure
effekt also den vertrauter als effekt
sachen die man oft gehört hat weil sie
oft wiederholt wurden kelling irgendwie
den für die leute ware oder
überzeugender
nun ist es aber auch so dass wenn man
einmal seine aufmerksamkeit einschaltet
und merkt man sofort wenn wir uns das
anschauen merkt man sofort das ist
irgendwie albern ja also sachen sie mal
zu wiederholen
also es funktioniert auch nur bei leuten
die schon eine gewisse voreinstellung
haben die politisch sowieso schon auf
der seite von jump sind und dann auch
noch nicht sich die mühe macht ein
bisschen drüber nachzudenken aber
natürlich bei wenn das ein teil der
wähler ist kann man die damit ansprechen
denn die man dinge zum beispiel
wiederholt oder besonders einfach
ausdrückt und gerade dieses konkrete
pilz der der mauer die gebaut werden
soll zum beispiel das sagt etwa die
deutsche linguistin elisabeth wenigen
ist achtet das sind konkrete bilder eben
geradezu frames die uns ins gehirn in
den kopf gesetzt werden die dann unser
denken in denken prägen und neben dem
gibt es auch noch diese emotionen sagt
sie also trump spielt auf angst er
spielt auf aggression und ekel
warum ist der ekel wichtig ja das ist
jetzt etwas was seinem psychologisch
mittlerweile ganz gut belegt ist
man weiß dass man wenn man die sagen wir
eher konservativen neigung in uns
ansprechen will muss man menschen
bilder vorgeben die irgendwas mit wickel
zu tun haben wie welche sprachliche
vermittlung man findet es eigentlich gar
nicht mehr so wichtig aber man weiß
einfach dass menschen alle so eine art
ekel mechanismus in sich haben ekels
erstmal der mechanismus der uns vor
fremdkörpern schützt also wir können uns
vor verdorbenem essen vor kadavern vor
experimenten aber wir können es auch vor
anderen menschen ekeln
und das ist stammesgeschichtlich in uns
tief verankert wie überschreiben dass in
der modernen kultur und sind versuchen
offene multikulturelle menschen zu sein
aber es gibt diesen hang wenn man in uns
das hervorruft dass eine bestimmte
menschengruppe abschaum ist eklig ist
minderwertig ungeziefer also wenn man
mit dieser sprache arbeitet kann man den
leuten eine neigung hervorrufen eine
bestimmte gruppe auch auszugrenzen aber
nicht den augen gleich stark also ist
das angeboren es gibt bestimmte leute er
sich genau also das ist es ist sozusagen
in allen erstmal diese disposition da
aber gleichzeitig ist die institutionen
wie sie gerade gesagt haben stark und
schwach ausgeprägt also jemand der
ohnehin eine stärkere ekel disposition
hat ist auch viel empfänglicher für
solche sprachbilder jemand der offen ist
was das betrifft und nicht so ein
starkes position hat ist weniger
empfänglich und das ist gleichzeitig das
ist auch relativ gut untersucht
korreliert mit politischen
positionierungen also leute die sich
eher im liberal links liberalen
progressiven spektrum empfinden haben
eher eine schwache ekel empfinden ein
schwaches ekel empfinden schwache
dispositionen menschen auf dem
konservativ rechten spektrum er eine
stärkere das heißt wenn man jetzt
politikberatung für einen konservativen
rechen machen würde müsste man ihm sagen
oder ihr sagen sprich den abgrenzen den
ekel in deinen wlan an hat sich auch
immer lustig machte er seine
konkurrenten wie stark die spitzen usw
das ist ein mechanismus dass man die
gegner als widerlegt als eklig hat
gesagt der einer seiner politischen
gegner dass der essen würde wie ein
schwein andere schwitzen oder wie sie
aussehen
also das sind typische mechanismen die
auch
seit jahrhunderten verwendet werden von
politikern um die gegensatz zu
diffamieren kommen wir noch einmal
zurück von den emotionen auch diese
bilder die unsere in unsere köpfe
gepflanzt werden und die elisabeth
welling ist schülerin von george lakoff
und der vertriebs die ziemlich radikale
these dass unser ganzes denken von
metaphern und sprachbildern durchdrungen
ist kann sie vielleicht mal ein beispiel
geben was meint er damit und und stimmt
diese these
ja also lake of hat die beobachtung
gemacht dass wir erst mal fangen wir
viele metaphern im alltag dir sagen so
was wie achill ist ein löwe oder mein
nachbar ist ein fuchs
ja wir wollen wir unser alltags
metaphern und black ops sagt das ist
aber nur ein spezialfall diese sprach
metaphern von einem viel allgemeineren
phänomen und er sagt unsere und sein
ganzes denken ist metaphorisch
strukturierten das kognitive metaphern
er sagt wenn wir über ein bestimmtes
thema nachdenken das abzweigen das
abstrakt ist verwenden wir immer sehr
sehr konkrete bilder ein beispiel dass
da gibt es wenn wir über den mit die
zeit nachdenken die zeit ist etwas nicht
greifbares abstraktes verwenden wir sehr
oft raum begriffe der raum den können
wir physisch erfahren in dem sind wir
drin wir können dinge im raum anfassen
uns im traum hin und her bewegen und
deshalb reden wir über die zeit im raum
begriffen wir sagen es gibt zeiträume
weihnachten kommt auf uns zu ostern
liegt hinter uns
ich gehe einen bestimmten weg ich habe
ein ziel vor augen also wir verwenden
für zeitliche dimensionen verwenden wir
oft raum begriffe und jetzt nach lake of
starke these wir können über zeit gar
nicht anders nachdenken als indem wir
raum begriffe verwenden oder wenn wir
über partnerschaft nachdenken verwenden
wir oft begriffe die irgendetwas mit
reise zu tun haben also man geht einen
weg gemeinsames kind das immer so fern
so hochzeit zu reden darf brauchen die
metapher manchmal sehr stark auf wir
erreichen zusammen ein ziel wir haben
uns gefunden um einen weg zu bestreiten
wir gehen jetzt getrennte wege sagen wir
auch ich habe das gefühl ich habe dich
verloren oder du hast da irgendeine
abzweigung genommen usw also diese
metaphern sind sehr produktiv und in
vielen sprachen vorhanden
aber es ist sie würden bestreiten dass
wir dass wir diese metaphern brauchen
also sie würden sagen man kann das auch
anders sagen das sind nicht zwingend
genau und sie ja nicht unser denken also
der lake of hat etwas wirklich
spannendes gefunden neu entdeckung
gemacht hat dann aber aus vielleicht
auch aus marketinggründen und
selbstdarstellungs gründen hat diese
these viel größer jetzt auf gebildet
wollte er ist ein ganz großer entdecken
cross machen
es gibt einfach sehr viele
gegenbeispiele einfach das gegenbeispiel
ist wenn ich sage meine tante ist ärztin
vollkommen metaphorisch also es gibt
ganz viele sätze wie wir äußern wo
überhaupt keine metapher drin ist das
das erste dann gibt es in deckung die
zeigen dass menschen zum beispiel raum
begriffe verlieren können und trotzdem
noch über die zeit reden können also es
gibt leute die haben störungen die
können sich nicht mehr räumlich nicht
mehr orientieren können auch mal
räumlich wenn ich mir so etwas sagen wie
wir treffen uns morgen am strand können
sie nicht mehr sagen aber wir können uns
die können immer noch sagen wir treffen
uns am dritten mai und dieses verorten
derzeit funktioniert ohne dass das
eigentliche verorten das ordentliche
worten mögliches leck auf würde sagen
ich kann nur die zeit verstehen nämlich
auch räumlich fordere das sind nur zwei
beispiele um zu zeigen dass es
eigentlich sehr übertrieben ist
wenn man in der heutigen
gesellschaftlichen debatten angucken
dann spielt sprache ja in ganz
verschiedenen hinsicht eine wichtige
rolle
es wird darüber diskutiert was überhaupt
noch gesagt werden darf und was nicht
mehr gesagt werden darf und der begriff
der politik und correctness ist dabei
ganz zentrale politische korrektheit
eine formulierung die im amerika der
90er jahre geprägt wurde
als kampfbegriff der konservativen
rechten gegen die liberale linke wie der
politgeograf michael hermann weiß mit
oder andere sprachregelung wir versuchen
diskriminiert die minderheit der beste
inspiziert weshalb begriffe wie [ __ ]
seither auf der schwarzen liste sind
andere bevölkerungsgruppen frauen etwa
erhalten zumindest sprachlich mehr
aufmerksamkeit sicher
sie war durch unabsichtliche bomber
versucht hat der fv hat der
amerikanische gesellschaft gekracht habe
easy political correctness spaltet
seither die usa die einen wollen
minderheitenschutz um jeden preis auch
wenn eher bizarre blüten treibt
die anderen sehen darin ein redeverbot
dass die öffentliche meinung und die
politische debatte lehnt wir können es
uns einfach nicht mehr leisten dermaßen
politisch korrekt zu sein wie es zu weit
mit der politiker correctness es kommen
muss im einzelfall entscheiden also erst
mal ist die beobachtung richtig das ist
eine große stellvertreter debatte die
politische korrektheit von der saar
linken progressiven seite ist eigentlich
da ist die idee eigentlich es geht um
minderheitenschutz geht darum dass
menschen durch worte nicht diffamiert
werden oder beleidigt werden das ist
dann auch wieder fremming um gefilmt
worden um formatiert worden von der eher
konservativen und rechten seite als
etwas als ein eingriff in die freiheit
wenn die einnahmen gesagt uns ist
mitgefühl fürsorge für die schwachen
wichtig deshalb wollen wir die sprache
ändern
die anderen gesagt nein das ist aber
eigentlich ein eingriff in meine
freiheit ich darf jetzt gar nicht mehr
sagen was ich sagen will freiheit wenn
die redefreiheit
also wird das gegeneinander ausgespielt
und ich glaube man kann das nicht
grundsätzlich entscheiden ob wir ob das
zu viel oder zu wenig isst man muss sich
jeden einzelfall anschauen weil es
einfach das weiß man wörter gibt die
eindeutig negativ besetzte tja also
[ __ ] oder haben ja gesagt mega das
sind wörter die kann man nicht mehr
sagen ohne die die familien zu verwenden
da kann keiner sich rausgehen und sagen
ich meine das aber neutral weil das
eindeutig so stark in unserer
gesellschaft negativ konnotiert ist ja
dort mittlerweile auch in deutschland
zum beispiel strafrechtlich verfolgt
wenn man jemanden so bezeichnet
gleichzeitig gibt es natürlich jetzt
diesen im sagen wir mal erblinden
progressiven spektrum einen neuen
diskurs dass leute überall sozusagen
beeinträchtigungen oder diffamierung
wittern aber vielleicht gar nichts da
ist es gibt so eine art über
sensibilisierung gerade im
amerikanischen des kurses gibt es
mittlerweile auch in deutschland ein
beispiel dass ich da immer ne ne ist
flüchtlingen es gibt jetzt einige sagen
flüchtlingen ist irgendwie als wort
schon negativ die sagen dann sollte man
jetzt ersetzen durch geflüchtet haben
und ich glaube die idee ist dass
nachfragen warum flüchtlingen negativ
und ich hab die genau die idee ist
dahinter dass bei dass ling irgendwas
negatives hat weil wir so etwas kennen
wie günstlingen oder schönling also in
einigen bildung des deutschen ist das
suffix die endung ling negativ wie
catering oder eben genau wir kennen aber
viele andere wörter wie lieblingen
schmetterlingen säugling pfifferling
findling engerling und so weiter wo das
ling eine neutrale oder vielleicht sogar
eine positive bedeutung hat aber
natürlich ist es so das ist das
interessante daran wenn genug leute eine
negative assoziation haben bei ling
selbst wenn es de facto von der
deutschen sprache gar nicht so
vorgegeben ist können irgendwann die
anderen die das neutral verwenden auch
nicht mehr neutral sein das ist einfach
eine spiel theoretische selbst
verstärkung sie müssen dann irgendwann
mit ziehen und dann entsteht so eine art
spirale das ist auch relativ gut
linguistisch untersucht nennt man
euphemismus tretmühle sondern pc spirale
dann fängt man an einen begriff er erst
neutral war beispiel das saarland wird
ist [ __ ] also für jemanden der
menschen mit behinderung hat mein erster
beitrag rüppel gesagt dann wird das
schnell negativ entweder es wurde
wirklich negativ verwendet als
schimpfwort oder dort haben daraus
negatives raus gehört da muss das
ersetzt werden durch ein neues wort
dann sagt man behindert schnell wird
aber behindert auch als abfällige
bezeichnung verwendet von einigen leuten
also muss es wiederum ersetzt werden
menschen mit behinderung oder menschen
mit herausforderungen und der die
beobachtung ist einfach die dass das
eine sprach kosmetik bleibt solange die
einstellung die dahinter liegt sich
nicht ändert und daran sieht man dass es
eigentlich nicht an dem wort hängt
sondern an der einstellung an der
herabwürdigenden einstellung gegenüber
menschen mit behinderung solange die da
ist kann wird das immer wieder als
schimpfwort egal was man da einsetzt
heuer werden negative konnotation legt
sich dann weiter was macht man dagegen
das kann nur dann weg gehen wenn sich
wie gesagt die einstellungen ändern was
erstmal zeigt dass es
sprachwissenschaftlich nicht das wort
selber ist was das negative trägt
sondern die einstellung die dahinter
steht und das heißt man muss an den
einstellungen arbeiten aber man kann
natürlich jetzt auch nicht sagen ich
habe die richtige einstellung also
verwende ich das wort einfach mal weil
dann mann ist nicht der herr über die
verwendung weise der wort in der eigenen
sprache muss ich dann auch ein bisschen
der mehrheit beugen würden sie das auch
bei der geschlechtergerechten sprache
sagen also wenn das man die weibliche
form nimmt oder das binnen-i oder auch
diese verschiedenen varianten dies dies
gibt ist er zu hause nur kosmetik aus
ihrer sicht ja das hat zwei aspekte also
es ist natürlich jetzt auch erstmal ein
sagen wir mal normativ moralisch
wichtiges programm weil es sagen erst
mal sagt wir wollen gleichstellung wir
wollen dass jetzt frau nicht irgendwie
benachteiligt sind das ist die grundidee
dahinter
ich halte es aber wissenschaftlich oft
für fragwürdig weil die grundidee
dahinter ist die dass man an der
generischen form an angeblich gleich an
ein mann denkt also wenn man jetzt was
hört wie direktor oder student dann
denken so die these die menschen eher an
einen mann und deshalb muss man sagen
studentin oder student studentin
studieren oder direktor direktorin und
wenn das so wäre wenn das wirklich so
sagen erst mal eine tatsache wäre dass
diese assoziation besteht das ja die
starke empirische these dann müsste es
zum beispiel so sein dass entsprachen
die kein genuss unterschied haben wie
das englische
da sagt man präsident oder boss ohne
dass klar ist ob das material feminist
müsste es ja dann schwächer sein
also wenn dieser effekt von der sprache
selber käme oder umgekehrt wenn man
sowas sagt wie stell dir mal vor da ist
eine lichtgestalt des fußballs eine
kurve in der festkörperphysik eine
person die mit dem flugzeug zum meeting
in frankfurt fliegt und da
aufsichtsrat mit den banking leuten sich
trifft bei all diesen beispielen sind
feminine domchor lichtgestalt personen
im spiel aber wir denken oft sofort an
einen mann wir denken nicht an den mann
weil das wort und das suggeriert war das
wort ist feminin sondern wir denken an
den mann weil wir bestimmte rollen
stereotype haben die gar nicht direkt
was mit der sprache zu tun hat dies
äußert sich vielleicht später mal in der
sprache aber die rollen stereotype die
kommen
die fangen im kindergarten anders in
zuschreibungen die wir machen und wie
gesagt diese idee dass durch die sprache
käme es in meinen augen so ein bisschen
sprach mystik die würde der sparsam war
so die mute der sprache zu viel macht zu
die sie gar nicht hat und übersieht dass
es eigentlich rollen rollenvorstellungen
sind die wir haben interessant jetzt
wollen wir noch ein bisschen
philosophisch werden und über sprache
und bedeutung ein bisschen anders
nachdenken weil bedeutung ist wirklich
ein philosophisches rätsel das ist also
die worte kann man es sehen und hören
aber die bedeutung selbst ist etwas das
man kaum fassen kann etwas unsichtbar
und es gibt ein wunderschöne
kindergeschichte vom schweizer autor
peter bichsel wo er einen alten mann
beschreibt dessen leben sehr monoton ist
unter wir was ändern und eines tages
fängt er an den dingen andere namen zu
geben
also sagte zum beispiel dem bett
plötzlich bild und dem stuhl sagt den
weggang mit der zeit änderte er sein
ganzes vokabular am ende jedoch endete
einsam und unglücklich zwar ist es
lustig für ihn jetzt unsere sprache zu
hören die nicht mehr versteht
aber man andere verstehen auch nicht
mehr und ich frage mich wie kommen
eigentlich bedeutung zu stande und wer
bestimmt eigentlich was so ein wort wie
tisch bedeutet ja das ist ganz große
philosophische frage die theorie mit der
peter bichsel da spielt ist die wird
manchmal scherzhaft haben die damit die
theorie genannt weil haben die damen die
bei alice im wunderland das auch so
ungefähr sagt er sagt was meine worte
bedeuten das bestimme immer noch ich so
die vorstellig könnte selber festlegen
was ich mit meinen worten bezeichnen
möchte
und das ist erst mal naiv weil sie
gesagt man wird nicht mehr verstanden
und man könnte auch eine sprache so gar
nicht lernen sprache ist ein so erstmal
im weiten sinne ein soziales phänomen
wir lernen sprache in einer
sprachgemeinschaft von sprechern die die
sprache aussprechen dass deutsche und
lernen es über gemeinschaftlichen umgang
mit den worten das ist erstmal das erste
dann gibt es aber jetzt in der
sprachtheorie zwei große lager die sich
streiten bis heute die sich fragen was
ist jetzt sozusagen der kern wie kann
ich die sprache erklären das eine lager
lager sagt sprache ist so etwas wie ein
abstraktes system von zeichen einer
großen gemeinschaft an der wir alle
teilnehmen ist vielleicht so eine
vorstellung wie zum beispiel
wittgenstein hatte
die regeln kennen nach denen worte
verwendet werden genau ist also
sozusagen eine eine sprachgemeinschaft
die nach bestimmten regeln in einer
großen lebensform eingebettet ist und
das gegenmodell dass ich jetzt so
ausgebildet hat er sagen wir mal in der
kognitiven psychologie durch noam
chomsky einem der wichtigsten bei dem
wichtigsten sprachwissenschafter des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts ist diese
vorstellung dass sprache dass man die
dann am besten verstehen kann wenn man
sich anschaut wie es unser geist heute
würde man vielleicht sagen und sagt
gehören strukturiert und wir sind wörter
oder auch solche regeln grammatischen
regeln wörter und begriffe in unserem
kopf abgespeichert und der ist chance
gesagt ja soweit ich weiß auch dass
unsere grammatik oder einen teil davon
wann geboren ist dass sprache etwas wien
instinkt ist wie steven pinker sagt der
amerikanische psychologe genau dass
damit ist schon berühmt geworden er
hatte die situation geschrieben mit 29
jahren und hat daraus ein kapitel als
buch veröffentlicht hat die gesamte
linguistik revolutioniert eigentlich
kann man sagen auch die gesamte
psychologie und hat mit einer sehr
eigentlich sehr naheliegenden these auf
die aber keiner so richtig gekommen ist
und hat gesagt sprache ist angeboren das
ist muss man sich vorstellen wie so ein
organ im kopf wie wir mit einem herz an
der lunge geboren werden dann wird
sozial mit einem sprachorgan geboren
das führt nicht automatisch dazu dass
wir eine sprache lernen genauso wie man
sagen kann wachstum ist angeboren aber
es führt nicht automatisch zu dass wir
wachsen also angeboren heißt nicht ist
sofort und was ein sondern es ist heißt
einfach nur es gibt eine starke
voreinstellung die braucht einen input
müssen essen um zu wachsen und wir
müssen sprachdaten bekommen damit dieses
sprachmodul gefüllt wird aber als eine
beobachtung war alle sprachen auf der
ganzen welt haben dieselbe grundstruktur
und die dieser apparat diesem diese
maschinerie unserem kopf wartet
sozusagen nur auf den einzelnen input ob
das jetzt chinesisch und englisch oder
deutsch ist und dann lernen die kinder
die sprache
ich habe eine kleine tochter die ist 18
monate die lernt gerade die sprache sie
kann erst einzelne wörter sagen mit der
zeit kommen dann irgendwann mal setzte
ich habe mich gefragt zum beispiel so
ein satz wie gestern war samstag den
kann sie nicht sagen denn wird ja auch
noch länger nichts sagen können liegt
das daran dass sie denen nicht denken
kann und wenn ja wie kann man so einen
satz wie gestern ist samstag denken ohne
sprache also wie was kommt da zuerst ja
da er sagt das ist ganz schwer zu lösen
da er weil unsere sprachfähigkeit also
chance gehabt jetzt die grammatik
untersucht also die frage wie setzte
strukturiert sind
und das ist natürlich nicht alles was um
die sprachfähigkeit ausmacht wir müssen
wörter haben wir müssen damit die regeln
haben wir die zusammensetzen also wenn
ich 5000 wörter des chinesischen kenne
kann ich noch kein chinesisch sprechen
weil ich noch nicht weiß wie ich die
zusammensetze zu ganzen sätzen dass ich
was äußern kann also ich brauche
struktur grammatik ich brauche die
wörter aber auch das reicht noch nicht
aus um eine sprache zu verstehen denn
ich muss ja auch wissen über die welt
haben
also das heißt wenn ich zeit begriffe
lernen muss sich auch ein verständnis
dafür haben wie die zeit abläuft und das
geht erst ab einem bestimmten alter also
bestimmte zeit begriffe lernen kinder
relativ spät
da müssen andere kognitive fähigkeiten
sich entwickelt haben
lustigerweise sagen kinder ja manchmal
sachen die sie noch nicht wissen können
also die nichte meiner freunde hat und
wann mal gesagt auch somit zu
dreieinhalb jahren ich fühle mich wie
neu geboren
da lacht man dann drüber weil weil das
irgendwie nicht sein kann dass die weiß
was sie damit meint bei kindern
natürlich dass es auch das was chance
gewartet hat ganz automatisiert alles in
sich aufsaugen und verarbeiten ohne dass
sie erst mal besonders darüber
nachdenken müssen also dieses dieses
phänomen das man mühelos automatisiert
die wörter in sich aufsaugt
und im gegensatz zu anderen fällen das
auch sehr schnell lernen dann wenn man
zum vergleich sehen wir haben wir
mathematik gelernt das war anstrengend
hat hat tränen und schweiß gekostet es
hat ganz viele jahre gedauert zwar
mühsam sprache haben wir alle gelernt
ohne diese anstrengung ohne dass wir
belohnt wurden es hat einfach so
funktioniert und das ist auch ein
starker indikator für die sachen geboren
heizt asse gibt es dann einen denken
auch nicht sprache ja dann muss man
immer diese philosophisch oder sagen wir
diese unbefriedigende antwort geben aus
philosophischer sicht kommt drauf an
kommt drauf an was man mitdenken meint
meint man mitdenken so etwas wie
schlussfolgern das was wir als planen
schlussfolgern reflexion
dann würde ich sagen dafür braucht man
eine eine struktur ein selbst wiederum
strukturierte denkfähigkeit ja das wird
manchmal die sprache des denkens
genannten metallisch mit dass jerry foto
hinter leser schutz sagen das ist die
struktur die wir alle haben wenn wir
nachdenken
es gibt eine schwächere ließ hat von
denken du warst man sogar sagt was so in
meinem kopf jetzt gerade vor sich geht
und das kann dann können ja tagträume
fantasien seien bilder wahrnehmungen und
dazu braucht man nicht unbedingt mit
sprache also für für dinge die jetzt
keine einzelnen schritte sind insofern
könnte man sagen tiere können auch
denken im sinne von dass sie sicherlich
auch eindrücke haben oder irgendwelche
bilder oder vorstellungen kann sein aber
denken im sinne von schlussfolgern von
allgemeinen zb zum besonderen kommen
worauf wir menschen besonders stolz sind
das ist sehr sehr unwahrscheinlich
ich möchte mit ihnen noch ein bisschen
darüber reden was es denn braucht um
eine andere person zu verstehen ob es da
reicht dass wir dieselbe sprache
sprechen ob wir diesen erfahrungen
gemacht haben müssen und wir haben von
der sternstunde philosophie haus
zusammen mit srf kultur kleine
animations- videos erstellt die heißt
ein philosophisches und eines davon
heißt gaga und widmet sich genau diesem
problem ob ihr jemand sicher sein können
eine andere person zu verstehen
stell dir vor du bist sprachforscherin
spezialisiert auf fremde sprachen seit
tagen bist du unterwegs im urwald
endlich triffst du auf den gesuchten
volksstamm dessen sprache zu erforschen
willst du brauchst ein lager etwas
abseits auf mit kamera und richtmikrofon
beobachtet das geschehen
er ist aufmerksam zu verstehst nur bei
anruf dann aber passiert etwas
interessantes sofort notiert du in der
notiz buchcover gleich haase
doch dann nach einigem überlegen kommen
die zweifel könnte der marica war gar
nicht auch unser abendessen gemeint
haben oder auf zur jagd oder heute
gibt's ein gewitter
du kommst zu dem schlussgang könnte
alles mögliche bedeuten
hasenfuß vielleicht auch affe wäre
möglich angenommen der mann sieht
schlecht
die zweifel daran dass du richtig
verstehst was gemeint ist häufen sich da
kommt ihr eine idee schnell zeichnest du
einen hasen kommst aus seinem versteck
hervor und gehst auf die romanze du
zeigst ihnen deine hasen zeichen und
fragst gaga er wedelt mit den armen
was hat das nun wieder zu bedeuten ja
oder nein
ratlos kirsten zu deinem unterschlug
zurück ist es zu hause mit der eigenen
sprache nicht auch so verstehen wir uns
da immer woher wissen wir eigentlich was
andere meinen wenn sie haase sagen
können wir jemals mit sicherheit wissen
was andere mit ihren worten nein ja eine
missliche situation wir kommen wieder
raus also dass sie haben
gedankenexperimente sowohl adenomen
klein amerikanischer philosoph sich
ausgedacht hat und das hat zwei
komponenten man kann ja sozusagen
kognitiv verstehen und erkenntnis
theoretisch wenn man es komplett
versteht sagt man erst mal was wo sie
überhaupt für fähigkeiten haben um
jemand anders zu verstehen
er hat sich so ein radikales beispiel
ausgedacht von einer fremden sprache
aber man kann das eigentlich auf sagt ja
auch selber auf die eigene muttersprache
anwenden weil alles was ich habe ist
sind die worte eines anderen und ich
muss ja immer davon ausgehen dass er mit
den worten irgendetwas meint jetzt wenn
ich die sprache auch gelernt habe habe
ich die hintergrund ein name der meint
ungefähr dasselbe mit seinen worten wie
ich mit meinen aber im prinzip ist das
auch nur hypothesen die ich habe über
den sprachgebrauch des anderen vereins
idee war wenn ich die worte für ja und
nein könnte aber doch philosophisch sang
für waren falsch einmal herausgefunden
habe dann kann ich gut testen ob das was
er über die welt denkt dasselbe ist wie
ich weil ich kann immer fragen und wenn
er ja sagt hatte auf einmal dieselbe
auffassung man nein sagt hatte auf meine
andere jetzt kann man natürlich auch
noch erkenntnistheorie machen kann sagen
naja drehen wir das doch mal ein
bisschen weiter könnte es nicht sein
dass der immer irgendwas sagt was ich
für ja und nein halte und auch diese
worte verwendet aber tatsächlich redet
ihr immer ein bisschen über was anderes
wir haben den eindruck wir verstehen uns
obwohl wir einander vielleicht vorbei
reden und er hat das so dargestellt dass
man sagen könnte wir können jetzt zwei
forscher in diesen dschungel schicken
unabhängig zu verschiedenen zeiten die
haben dann beide so perfekt übersetzungs
handbücher gebaut für die sprache also
haben sozusagen eine interpretations
theorie in einem buch form von algari
und auch in möglichen allen hört dann
sieht wie gesagt haben plötzlich
vergleichen wir die bücher und sehen die
sind inkompatibel war seine these ich
glaube dass diese erkenntnistheoretische
these die ist ja kann man sich darüber
streiten wenn man erkennt dass theorie
mag in dieser art und skeptizismus mag
ich halte ich für nicht plausibel aber
man kann es wie gesagt auch kognitiv
lesen und dann muss man sich klar machen
eine sprache verstehen heißt nicht nur
die worte den dingen zuzuordnen sondern
man muss auch den menschen die man
interpretiert bestimmte überzeugung über
die welt zu ordnen man muss sie
eigentlich sich vorstellen dass das
wesen sind die ungefähr dieselben
überzeugung über die ihre umwelt haben
die wir auch haben und das ist etwas was
sein schüler davidson auch ein sehr
einflussreicher sprachphilosoph
amerikaner dann in eine ganze
interpretations theorie ausgebaut hat es
braucht wohl wollen oder ein prinzip des
forderns und ohne das kommt man
irgendwie nicht wirklich genau wird das
dann auf den punkt gebracht dass er
gesagt hat wir müssen eigentlich den
anderen immer erst mal als rationales
wesen sehen dass er dass er ungefähr
konsistente überzeugung hat von der welt
ich muss von ihnen jetzt annehmen dass
sie wären sie dahin kommen auch da
bücher sehen und das auch als bücher die
auch als bücher anerkennen und wissen
dass das da buchstaben sind die da drauf
stehen und ganz viele anrufer zeugung
das mache ich nicht bewusst aber das
muss ich sozusagen dauernd unterstellen
sonst könnten wir gar nicht darüber
reden ob das eine buch besser ist als
das andere was man spielen wenn man mit
fremden sprachen und kulturen in kontakt
kommt dann gibt es oft schwierigkeiten
bei der übersetzung waren bestimmte
worte bei uns nicht mit einem wort
übersetzt basis weiter und man hat
manchmal den eindruck dass in
unterschiedlichen sprachen auch
unterschiedliche weltbilder oder
mentalitäten zum zum ausdruck kommen
darüber möchte ich mit ihnen noch ein
bisschen sprechen inwiefern denn die
sprache unser denken prägt uns
der berühmte deutsche philosoph und
bildungsreformer wilhelm von humboldt
hat im 19 jahrhundert die these
aufgestellt dass in jeder sprache
eigenen eine eigentümliche weltansicht
legt was halten sie von dieser these sie
sprach ist das bilden organ der gedanken
sagt humboldt und hat diese vorstellung
gehabt die ein zusprachen prägen das
denken der menschen diese these ist
berühmt geworden als said one of these
auch genannten linguistische
relativitätstheorie klingt etwas sperrig
sagt eigentlich nur das irgendwie die
sprache unser denken festlegt die
gegenthese würde sagen nee wird können
denken was ist unabhängig davon welche
ein zu sprache wir sprechen und können
das in den verschiedenen einzel sprachen
ausdrücken das ist die unabhängigkeit
these und die humboldtsche these und die
die relativitätstheorie sagt nein die
sprache ist das medium der gedanken also
die gedanken sind sozusagen schon
sprachlich verfasst und dann kann man
sehr schnell sagen wenn die sprachen
sich sehr stark unterscheiden müssen die
gedanken auch ganz anders sein
und das beispiel was dafür immer gegeben
wird ist gleichzeitig der größte mythos
in der sprachwissenschaft das ist
nämlich kennt man auch aus dem alltag
ist diese vorstellung die eskimos hätten
sehr viele schnee wörter und würden
deshalb schnee also könnten bei schnee
anders nachdenken indem sie könnten
schnee besser wahrnehmen
das ist die differenzierte finanzierter
genau das ist in die welt gesetzt wurden
von einem deutschen anthropologen franz
boas der erstmal untersuchung gemacht
bei denen indigenen völker im polarkreis
und hat rausgefunden bestimmen expo
sprachen gibt es vier fälle oben
verschiedene staaten auszudrücken
und dann hat der wolf das war so ein
eigentlich eher so eine art hobby
sprachwissenschaftler der hat eine ganz
starke tesa hat sagt die haben viele
wörter für schnee und dann habe ich
mehrere autoren wurden dass immer mehr
und machen selbst gibt hunderte wörter
für schnee
in diesen sprachen tatsächlich gibt es
nur vier und in dem wenn man das
vergleicht mit dem deutschen im
deutschen gibt es auch ganz viele schnee
wörter haas führen
graupel schloss
matsch schnee sulzschnee neuschnee und
wenn man skifahrer viermal zehn andere
das ist unglaublich leicht neue wörter
herauszufinden und es gibt überhaupt
keine korrelation zwischen der vielfalt
der wörter und der fähigkeit etwas zu
unterscheiden also das war ein ganz
großer mythos und die aber diese art von
gedanken stecken hinter dieser these
dass irgendwie die strukturen die wörter
oder irgendwas der einsprache unser
denken beeinflusst aber es gibt ja schon
auch indizien für diese für diese these
also etwa experimente die gemacht wurden
mit farben zum beispiel das bestimmt ist
im geschwind binden sprachen glaube ihm
im russischen oder im griechischen gibt
es zwei wörter für blau solchen dunkel
und hell und sie können danach ein
bisschen schneller und besser
unterscheiden zwischen diesen
farbeindruck oder es gibt etwa das
beispiel das gi deutschland ist der
rheinische linguist nennt vom
dramatischen geschlecht dass das
sozusagen unsere assoziationen bestimmt
das heißt im spanischen heißt die brücke
heißt el puente also eigentlich männlich
geprägt und brands die brücke weiblich
und die assoziation im spanischen sind
eher so müssen männlich aus einem brück
ist stark und man sich sehr grazil und
so weiter oder bei den aborigines hat
man untersuchungen gemacht die denken
überraschender weise nicht in links und
rechts sondern in nördlich und südlich
ja und egal wo sie stehen ob sie die
sonne sehen oder nicht können immer
unterscheiden würden
wo sie gerade stehen ob sie nach norden
drucken oder nach sich
das heißt es scheint schon solche
indizien zu geben dass die sprache was
denken prägt auf den ersten blick ja und
es gibt die so gesamten neogaf jana also
die diese alte these die eigentlich
erkenntnistheoretische schnell vom tisch
gewischt wurde sozusagen neu beleben
wollen die sagen jetzt nicht mehr so was
wie die sprache bestimmt oder
determiniert unser denken unser weltbild
aber sie hat einen einfluss darauf ein
bisschen schwächere these und die
beispiele die agi deutschland nennt sind
alle sehr spannend wenn man sich die
genauer anguckt merkt man oft dass die
gar nicht immer was mit der sprache zu
tun haben ich mache mal dieses beispiel
mit den aborigines das sind das ist ein
dessen die gute chemie dir das ist in
hopewell gebiet in queensland in
australien leben die und die sind
untersucht worden von anthropologen den
90er jahren und die haben herausgefunden
dass die einen orientierungssinn haben
der vergleichbar ist mit seinem inneren
gps die können sich immer ein norden und
zwar mit einer abweichung von etwa 14
grad auf 350 kilometer also eine
fähigkeit die von der wirecard finder
träumen würde fast immer dabei immer den
inneren kompass dabei und die haben die
sozusagen in dunkle räume gesetzt und um
sich selber gedreht habe wo es norden
also deren äquivalent von norden und die
können sagen dass norden oder sind durch
die wüste gefahren stern lose nacht und
wir konnten sich immer ein norden und
jetzt ist es so dass die sprache von
denen nur ein absolutes
koordinatensystem hat also die kennen
nur für orientierung norden süden osten
westen also entsprechende ausdrücke
dafür während wir uns oft intrinsisch
motivieren wir sagen so was wie geh mal
links mal rechts rum also an an unserer
eigenen körper mitte orientiert oder an
relativen bezugspunkten in der natur wir
sagen was bei der kirche rechts oder
games zum markt da hinten rüber
jetzt könnte man denken oh die sprache
führt dazu dass sie das können ja die
die weil die sprache kennt ja nur norden
süden westen osten führt dazu lassen
können und diese korrelation gibt es ist
kann man kann leute mit einer sprache
dazu bringen also durch äußere zwänge
dazu bringen eine fähigkeit zu
entwickeln nur kann man zeigen diese
fähigkeit kann man auch so entwickeln es
gibt eine andere untersuchung in
mexiko da gibt es zwei völker die heißen
zelt 1 und 2 thiel ist jetzt kein witz
sondern sie leben beide am selben
berghang nebeneinander die eine haben
ein absolutes koordinatensystem und
können sich genauso absolut orientieren
die anderen haben eine sprache die wie
unsere spare mehrere orientierung fans
können sich aber auch perfekt
orientieren weil die einfachen deren
umwelt ist es unglaublich wichtig zu
wissen was ist unterhalb des hanges um
was es oberhalb des hanges und deshalb
haben lernen das von klein auf und das
hat man auch bei den gourmet die
herausgefunden so bald in einem anderen
gebiet sind die sind dann mit dem
flugzeug mal nach melbourne geflogen und
plötzlich konnten sie sich dann nicht
mehr orientieren weil sie nicht mehr
diese feinen justierung hatten und sich
nicht mehr so gut in der welt zurecht
finden darin also man auf den ersten
blick wirkt es so als sei es die sprache
gewesen auf den zweiten blick muss man
sagen er die sprache war vielleicht
indirekt der weg durch den sie zu diesen
fähigkeiten bekommen sind aber die
fähigkeiten kann man auch so entwickeln
aber es ist eher die lebensform es die
sprache
peter bieri ein schweizer film von peter
rathmann absatz geschrieben über bildung
und schreibt darin wer sand
begriffliches repertoire erweitert kann
zitatende versierter über sein erleben
reden und das wiederum ermöglicht die
differenziert dazu empfinden also
ähnlich wie die ssg these ich finde das
aber klar sie werden hier auf gefühle
und hat mir unser innenleben sharon oder
also aber auch wenn ich zum beispiel in
der musik sondern ausdruck der dominanz
ad akkord lerne dann werde ich in
zukunft doch viel aufmerksamer sein was
dieses phänomen betrifft genau das ist
sehr gut belegt und das würde ich sagen
sind die beiden empirischen ergebnisse
die man daraus ziehen kann ich würde das
jetzt nicht mehr legen muss sich
relativitätstheorie oder neofaschismus
nennen aber man kann sagen durch
sprachliche kategorien kann man die
aufmerksamkeit schulen das kann man
besonders bei der wahrnehmung zeigen
also weinkenner wenn die die richtigen
begriffe haben können die plötzlich da
geschmacksnuancen entdecken die man als
laie nicht entdeckt wenn man sich mit
musik auskennt kann man plötzlich sachen
raus hören die man früher nicht
heraushören konnte das innenleben ist
ein gutes beispiel dafür
also aufmerksamkeit dafür sensibilisiert
uns manchmal die sprache indem wir die
feineren begriffe bilden können wir auch
die aufmerksamkeit seiner justieren und
das zweite ist die erinnerungsfähigkeit
das sind diese farbexperimente also
menschen können ungefähr eine millionen
farben unterscheiden wenn man jetzt hier
ausbreitet man kann zwei fahrten kann
sagen jetzt noch ein bisschen heller das
noch ein bisschen dunkler das rot aber
wie gesagt hier schauen mal dieses rot
dreh dich mal um und versucht das wieder
zu entdecken zwischen ganz vielen
anderen roth paletten das fällt uns
extrem schwer
da können wir vielleicht hellrot und
dunkelrot noch unterscheiden das heißt
unsere unterscheidung fähigkeit ist
feiner als unsere erinnerungsfähigkeit
an die farb kategorien und da kann man
zeigen menschen die sich mit farben
beschäftigen entweder durch ihre
muttersprache oder einfach auch durch
ihren beruf sagen wir mal diesen
modebranche
die können dann plötzlich sagen wir mal
einen lachs lachsfarben das von einem
altrosa unterscheiden aber der laie für
den ist das nur irgendwie rosa und
jemand der noch nie x 90 x rosa gelernt
hat für den ist das vielleicht roth ja
und so kann man auch diese experimente
zwischen den russischen sprechern gut
erklären wenn da eine unterscheidung
gemacht werden muss sprachlich zwischen
grün und blau
dann ist es auch leichter für die diesen
unterschied schneller zu erkennen und
sich die unterschiede auch zu merken und
den zu kategorisieren aber das heißt
nicht dass man sich auch so lernen gibt
es sprachen die näher an der realität
dran sind aus andere halte ich für
extrem unwahrscheinlich also wenn chance
gerächt hat dann sind alle sprachen
ungefähr gleich komplex man kann
natürlich in mehr wörter oder weniger
wörter lernen ja in die menschen am
großen wortschatz am rahmen klein aber
sagen wir von der struktur und den
grundprinzipien sind alle straßen
straßen schon alle sprachen gleich
komplex und dadurch kann man auch nicht
sagen dass sprachen irgendwie näher an
der wirklichkeit dran sind und könnte
auch philosophisch dann ist es ohnehin
ein bisschen fragwürdige metapher weil
die sprache ist das mittel um die welt
zu repräsentieren ja also nicht direkt
abzubilden aber eine repräsentation zu
bilden sondern eine art modell der welt
zu bilden ist auf jeden fall dafür
sprache es ist eine funktion die sprache
hat und es ist nicht so dass man mit der
sprache an die dinge heran kommt es gibt
in der romantik und bei nietzsche finden
wenn man so formulierungen die so diese
idee haben dass man
immer weg ist von den dingen die dinge
irgendwie näher rankommen und vielleicht
gibt es dann nicht sprachliche wege um
irgendwie näher ran zu kommen über die
wahrnehmung hat man vielleicht noch
einen besseren zugang zur wirklichkeit
ich glaube das ist wird geschehen würde
sagen sie ein sprachbild selbst das
einen gefangen hält eine falsche
metapher die zugang zur realität genau
an realität ausgeht als etwas wo man
einen zugang hat im sinne von näher oder
weiter weg sein aber wenn man sich so
nicht in unsere natürliche sprache
unserer alltagssprache anschaut dann
gibt es viele ungenauigkeiten
doppeldeutigkeiten und in der
philosophie gab es ja diese bewegung hin
zu einer idealen sprache mit der man
dann die realität genau treffen kann und
sozusagen die sprache der natur zu
finden in den wissenschaften ist es
vielleicht die mathematik deswegen habe
ich schon den eindruck nicht jede
sprache ist leicht differenziert könnte
man vielleicht sagen und differenzierter
desto mehr sieht man von der welt wäre
das eine
wenn man es so ausdrücken dann kommt man
wieder in diese richtung gehen wenn man
feinere begriffe hat kann man mehrere
unterschiede wahrnehmen aber
grundsätzlich muss man sagen und so
sprache ist immer ein versagen des
kontinuierliches mittel um etwas
kontinuierliches zu beschreiben also die
welt ist unglaublich reichhaltig und
gefüllt so zu sagen sie es maximal und
besticht würden philosophen sagen also
viele feine unterscheidung und erst
schneiden und hier schneiden genau wir
schneiden mit wörtern sagen wir so ich
sag jetzt einfach dass das ist ein tisch
und habe jetzt ein unglaublich komplexes
molekül gebilde einfach mit einem wort
sozusagen vereinfacht und in der weise
sprache immer eine vereinfachung weil
wir nie ran kommen an die detaillierte
beschreibung der welt der herrenberger
keine zeit und auch nicht an dieses
individuum an dieses an diesen
einzelfall tisch weil das wort tisch
gilt ja für andere alle anderen tischen
natürlich auch und deswegen also sie
haben nie genannt
der hat ja es gab diese dieses diese
zweifel an der an der sprache in 19 20
wir haben das die sprache und irgendwie
diesen zugang zur realität verstellt
durch metaphern ja durch vorurteile die
mit transportiert werden aber auch durch
diese allgemeinheit
der einzelfall immer untergeht in der
sparte man ganz einfach sagen kann
dieser tisch ja wir haben demonstrativ
grund um damit verwenden also die bahn
erst mal richtig wir haben begriffe und
begriffe sind könnte man sagen
kategorien schubladen wenn ich sage
tisch
diesen begriff in meinem kopf habe dazu
habe ich auch das wort tisch muss gar
nicht das deutsche wort sein könnte auch
table sagen also ich habe eine mentale
kategorie das ist wie eine schublade da
gehören jetzt alle tische rein
ja und ich kann nicht verwenden um auf
jeden einzelnen tisch bezug zu nehmen
und dann schaue ich jetzt die
individualität dieses tisches zu
negieren wenn ich das ding hier tischen
dann aber das ist dieser eine tisch der
an diesen raum zeit stellen ist es gibt
doch so viele andere ich neben dem die
individualität aber wenn ich über dieses
einzel den gesprächen will dann mache
ich genau dass ich zeigen mit dem finger
auf und sage dieser tisch oder ich sage
der einzige tisch der in diesem studio
steht also es gibt sprachliche mittel um
auf einzelgänger bezug zu nehmen und man
nimmt den einzelnen nicht ihre
individualität nur weil man sie in eine
größere gruppe packt also wenn man sagt
ich bin ein mann nimmt man ihm nicht
meine individualität nur weil man
nämlich eine sehr große gruppe wo drei
milliarden andere individuen sind hat
man auch bei jeder beschreibung des
tisches fehlt etwas oder wenn ich sagen
da ist paar jahren dann kommen wir nicht
ran da ist so und so hat sich auch das
wasser und soll dann hat man das große
thema romantik
ja ich glaube das ist der mythos der uno
aus druckbarkeit des individuellen das
ist diese vorstellung es gibt das
individuelle die einzel dinge und die
können wir sprachlich nicht erschöpfen
die sind unerschöpflich
die der tisch hat doch so viele einzelne
moleküle und ist doch so in seiner
individualität so reichhaltig ich kann
dann kommen da nicht dran dass wir die
gleiche metapher an dieser vorstellung
man müsste an die dinge heran kommen
manchmal sogar diese idee man müsste sie
sogar dadurch erschaffen dadurch dass
man darüber spricht das ist ein falsches
bild über die funktion von sprache wenn
ich ein modell habe für etwas ist das
modell nicht die sache selbst wenn ich
sage ich spreche über diesen tisch ist
das wort tisch oder die beschreibung
tisch nicht der tisch selber ich muss
den ich in seiner ganzheit erfassen und
ich muss ein individuum in einer
kategorie herausgreifen hier wieder mal
ein bisschen zurück von philosophischen
weg in den alltag wenn wir anschauen wie
wir heute kommunizieren ist das oft
auf dem handy digital per mail und da
ist seit einigen jahren gibt es ein
phänomen das immer mehr bilder auch
verwendet werden
zeichen die sich der sogenannte coaches
sie sind überall begleiten uns zur
arbeit in die pause und in die freizeit
die kleinen bildzeichen haben einzug
gehalten in unseren alltag
ob wir wollen oder nicht mehrere
milliarden stück werden pro tag
verschickt ein ausdruck unserer zeit
[Musik]
friedensnobelpreisträger kommunizieren
genauso mit ihm wie sport stars
sogar die eher konservative bbc
berichtet über das königshaus gerne mal
mit kies und der ritterschlag geht
weiter legendäres von shakespeare oder
das meistverkaufte buch der welt gebiet
allesamt mit kies durchsetzt ja warum
können diese musik so eine
erfolgsgeschichte feiern
ich glaube die erfolgsgeschichte der emo
dies hängt direkt zusammen mit der
schriftlichen kommunikation der
mündlichen kommunikation nutze ich alle
informationen von meinem gegenüber die
ich habe und nutze auch oft gestik und
mimik und kann so zum beispiel ironie
oder humor sehr gut erkennen in der
schriftlichen kommunikation geht das
nicht so gut ich kann was schreiben und
es könnte vielleicht lustig ironisch
gemeint sein aber es ist irgendwie
semantisch unter bestimmt kann man sagen
manchmal weiß man das nicht so genau und
um sicher zu gehen haben die leute
irgendwann angefangen bei der
schriftlichen kommunikation humor marker
zu setzen das ist die erfolgsgeschichte
smileys und dass miley hat den anfang
gemacht und dann fängt man an wo man
sich gesagt hat na ja viele emotionale
oder inhaltliche phänomene kann ich doch
ganz gut und schnell mit einem zeichen
ausdrücken ohne dass ich da viele worte
verlieren muss also ich könnte sagen
wenn ich bin gut gelaunt aber ich kann
auch einen kleinen smiley modell setzen
ich kann sagen ich bin wütend aber ich
kann auch einfach einen kleinen wütenden
demo zu setzen es vereinfacht vor allen
dingen den ausdruck von gefühlen aber es
hilft vor allem die kommunikation
sozusagen das ganze kontext wissen was
wir normalerweise eine mündliche
kommunikation haben zu ersetzen oder
beizusteuern hat man dann weniger
interpretation bei gesichtern bei mimik
ist das etwas das universell
verständlich ist
man braucht interpretationen immer aber
natürlich ist es so dass bestimmte mimik
und gestik universelles weil wir einfach
bestimmte gesichtsausdrücke haben also
freundlichkeit wird immer gleich
ausgedrückt das ist auch angeboren ist
auch in allen kulturen gleich also
lächeln bestimmte grund emotionen zeigen
sich im gesichtsausdruck über gleich das
ist ja auch der grund warum das weltweit
funktionieren kann einige modistin so
kulturspezifische die verwenden wir auch
falsch wie kommt man aus koriander eine
ganz andere bedeutung als
aber viele sind einfach universell weil
der gesichtsausdruck universelles wenn
wir müssen in die zukunft blicken dann
können wir sagen dass wir wahrscheinlich
vermehrt mit künstlichen systemen
kommunizieren werden mit sogenannten
sprachassistenten so etwas wie siri zum
beispiel und der vision als dazu noch
mal einen kurzen die it industrie
arbeitet daran künstliche intelligenz
alltagstauglich zu machen
bei google in zürich entwickelt der
bioinformatiker bis hat bielsa die und
sein team ein intelligentes system für
smartphones genannt assistent und das
soll weit mehr können als eine bisherige
google suche kann
der größte unterschied liegt darin dass
heute eine sehr natürliche konversation
möglich ist man kann mit dem assistant
genauso sprechen wie mit einem menschen
nicht zum beispiel erfahren möchte wie
das wetter morgen wird ob es regnen wird
oder so dann muss ich nur fragen werde
ich werde in zukunft mit mit siri oder
ähnlichen systemen genauso sprechen
können die mit ihnen jetzt also man hat
den der die suggestion bei diesen
spracherkennungssystem ist ja immer dass
das dass die man sprache verstehen
können und intelligent sind und das ist
selber wiederum fremming wie vom anfang
besprochen haben diese darstellung dass
maschinen intelligent sind sowie
menschen intelligent sind obwohl sie
erst mal klar machen die verstehen
natürlich überhaupt keine sprache sind
aber mittlerweile so gut programmiert
dass man das von außen nicht mehr
richtig merkt also sind so programmiert
dass es einem nicht mehr auffällt so als
ob sie verstehen genau das ist eine sehr
gute simulation aber wenn man jetzt das
philosophisch betrachtet wenn ich etwas
simuliere
doch mittlerweile stofftiere die bewegen
sich und verhalten sich wie richtige
tiere dann ist mir aber klar nur weil er
rund sich so verhält als sei eher
freudig ist ja nicht wirklich freudig
weil es einfach ein roboter ist genauso
nur weil siri worte an mich gerichtet
sind das keine äußerungen oder keine
aufforderung oder keine behauptungen
also sie spricht nicht buchstäblich mit
mir aber es gibt keine prinzipielle
krenzer es kann irgendwann sagen dass
ich bei einem sprachassistenten nicht
mehr merken ob da ein mensch dahinter
ist oder eine maschine
das hat man schon den 60er jahren
bewiesen es gibt ein berühmtes programm
das heißt je leiser das hat joseph
weizenbaum gebaut das sagt hat immer nur
so eine art sprach bot heute immer nur
gesagt erzählt mir mehr davon
das ist ja interessant rc mehr davon und
wenn sie dann gesagt haben ja ich habe
ein bisschen probleme zu hause 8 zu
hause ist es schlimm erzählt mir mehr
davon
und da eine mehrzahl der personen die
mit diesem 60er jahre also wirklich
einfachste computertechnologie
interagiert hat mit diesem system hatte
schon den eindruck da hat mir einer zu
das ist das ist einer der immer wirklich
ernst nimmt
sie hatten ganz schnell den eindruck das
ist ein mensch der dahinter steckt das
heißt wir menschen haben ohnehin diese
neigung alles zu vermenschlichen
zimmerpflanzen stofftiere haustiere
sobald etwas einigermaßen sich wie ein
mensch verhält denken wir das ist ein
denkender mensch deshalb funktionierte
maschinen so gut aber das heißt nicht
dass wir uns wirklich verstehen aber
braucht es um diese sprachkompetenz zu
haben nicht auch sehr viel wissen oder
angebliches wissen also welt wissen über
die welt wo wir das diskutiert haben mit
mit meiner tochter die jetzt greift die
sprache lernt lernt nicht nur die
sprache sondern eben auch die welt genau
das wäre also die these ist die kritik
die man geäußert wird ist zu sagen ja
die können wirklich nicht sprache
verstehen aber wenn ich den jetzt genug
informationen über die welt gäbe die wir
auch haben dann würden um schon
verstehen also die information haben sie
erstmal schon mal nicht aber natürlich
wird man sagen jetzt programmiert so
dass die bei google da alles auf alle
informationen zugriff haben aber dieses
verständnis wie man wirklich mit der
welt hinter agiert dass man sich
gemeinsam auf dinge bezieht was viele
philosophen davidson die man schon
genannt haben denn das triangulation
also dass diese gemeinsame referenz dass
zwei sprecher sich auf ein objekt
beziehen und das bezeichnen darüber
geben
das ist zum beispiel solche maschinen
gar nicht vorhanden ganz zum schluss
noch wenn die sprache so etwas ist wie
ein schlüssel zum verständnis des
menschen
was ist das wichtigste war dass wir
lernen wenn wir die sprache des menschen
betrachten obersten schwierige frage wir
können unabhängig von unserer direkten
umwelt über alles nachdenken das ist das
was die menschen besonders macht wir
können über fairness zukünftiges
vergangenes mögliches unmögliches
fantastisches nachdenken und das ist
etwas was uns menschen vom tier
unterscheidet weil die tiere sind an die
situation in ihrem alltag direkt
gebunden und wir können ja mit unseren
gedanken haben sprachliche die grünen
überall in sprache ermöglicht uns
distanz vielen dank herr über
clubsprecher ja nächste woche begrüßt
sie barbara bleisch bereits um 10 uhr
und zwar aus irland in einer
zweistündigen sendung spricht sie unter
anderem mit einer druidin mit martin
alioth und mit dem bestseller-autor
konkubinen über die kelten über
religionen darüber wie es in irland nach
dem break cit weitergeht jetzt gleich
sehen sie in der sternstunde kunst ein
porträt über sunita eine junge afghanin
die mit rap gesang gegen ihre
zwangsheirat protestierte und damit die
youtube gemeinde begeisterte vor dem
film gibt es aber noch einen kleinen
denkanstoß für den fall dass sie noch
etwas zu erledigen haben nicht in der
zukunft sondern in der vergangenheit
bleiben sie also dran und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]